c'est vrai que quand vous êtes en retard
ils dansent au plouc sofia tout trouvé
les gants mais mon à houla l'annonçait
sais pas qui sait si wes et toi et moi
je sais qu'il a très grand succès avec
les filles je joue c'est vrai quoi vous
sort vraiment vraiment si elle se
demande ça te demande si tu es vraiment
mannequin ça oui le week-end parce que
la semaine je fais bah oui non mise en
regard regardent sans rien me l'a dit
blague à part la boucle en rigolent et
tout ça mais moi je vous dis raymond a
beaucoup de succès avec les femmes
agissent avant jc la mairie raymond a
une gueule de cinoche avérée dans un
film d'olivier marchal part c'est vrai
dit ah oui c'est vrai alors il a franchi
depuis mai bien mai devienne tête un
bassin film d'olivier marchal c'est non
mais non mais c'est pourquoi il plaît
pourquoi faire n'importe quoi regrette
pas de parler derrière moi si ça vous
plaît il est brut de pomme met à rêver
des chewing de pauvres alors la vérité
c'est qu'ils sont le cube six ans le cul
c'est là qu'on voit qu'ils aiment le cul
maintenant on parle de ses pizzas
excusez moi oui partir de cas isolés
dini comme le pétage de plomb non mais
juste
mais non mais on voit qu'ils aiment ça à
me sentais ce sont plus des pics du cul
alors là
merci à l'état